what was the poll question mclovin who
would you bet a week's pay will not be
the NFL playoffs but we need some help
narrowing down the teams now we lifted
this from Mike Florio because mike has
the show prior to this one on the NBC
sports network in fact let's bring in
Mike Mike we did we sampled from your
show without permission by the way but
thanks for joining us what was the
answer that you were getting from your
audience the permission is implied
anything you want to sample anything you
want to borrow anything you just want to
take you are more than welcome to
anything I have because they don't have
much I I thought my own thought is the
Browns are the number one team that has
no chance to make it to the playoffs
this year because number one in the
division they play in a number two I
don't think they want to make it to the
playoffs this year I think they're
building for 2017 and Beyond and I think
the 49ers as well but you know that we
had a broad range I owe somebody
suggested Broncos to say the Broncos
have no chance to make the playoffs i
think is maybe wishful thinking by
Raiders fans I think they they have a
chance there are many teams you can look
at and say you have no chance of making
it and i think the browns in the AFC and
the 49ers in the NFC are the two that
would be the closest to saying you have
no chance this year thank you for
playing thank you for being the
opponents for the other teams they need
to play somebody but you're not going to
be in the postseason this year give me
the team or teams that you think make
that big leap it feels like there's a
quantum leap taken by at least two teams
every year yeah but the problem is we
get on those teams right well of the
Jaguars they write the Jaguars the first
thing we think about this you're all the
Jaguars all they're going to be so much
better Blake bortles coming into year
three he was second in the NFL touchdown
passes last year and he's got Allen
Robinson and Allen Hurns and have all
the defensive players he's young guys
like Dante Fowler Myles Jack i wanna i
want to see it before i buy it because i
feel like there's too much you know i
look at the Jaguars and the Titans and I
say a ton of buzz about the Jaguars no
buzz about the Titans wouldn't I rather
be the Titans would never be the team
that nobody expects anything from look
at the Saints in the NFC South they have
one of the best quarterbacks in the
history of football and drew brees and
nobody is saying the Saints are going to
make it to the playoffs they're one of
the roughest training camps they
ever had James Laurinaitis who joined
the team this year from the Rams said it
was the the most physical training camp
he's seen since the new CBA was put in
place you know that so the real
surprises are the teams that we aren't
trying to flag so a team like the titans
and the same that would really be a
surprise because we're not saying hey
look at them were saying look at the hey
watch out for the Jaguars watch out for
the Buccaneers watch out for this team
and how often to those teams actually
pan out micro often Mike Florio join us
course profootballtalk.com and 7 a-9
eastern on the NBC sports network every
morning back to the Browns Josh Gordon
are the Browns shopping him or teams
just inquiring about Josh Gordon well
you know I love nothing more than a
little ESPN on ESPN crime Dan and as it
turns out there was a report yesterday
from ESPN that teams were calling and
then ESPN Cleveland reported today that
the Browns leaked at the ESPN to
generate interest oh the dog is chasing
at the tail and and ESPN is riding the
dog while it does so so who knows but
look the browser trusted this guy
multiple times and every time they trust
and me ends up suspended again and if
they truly are building for the future
then trade him get what you can for him
get some draft picks for next year and
lay the foundation to make your team
better in 2017 because I don't think you
can reliably say hey we're definitely
going to have Josh Gordon in 2017 and
2018 because every time they think they
have him he gets suspended again al
Jazeera report with Peyton Manning is
where it started back in January and
people dismissed it because it was Al
Jazeera and of course Peyton Manning
would never use HGH yeah and then all of
a sudden there were other names attached
to it there are other sports attached to
this if this is a different news outlet
are we taking it are we looking at it
differently than what we have been oh
absolutely oh absolutely because that
was part of the initial dismissal of the
report remember Mike Ditka when he was
on ESPN as its disreputable and you know
they don't listen anything they have to
say well okay fine but you know it's out
there and now we gotta deal with it in
the NFL at least viewed it as
sufficiently credible to investigate
and the thing that gets me though Dan is
once you decide that the guy who was
recorded without his knowledge from the
Guyer Institute in Indianapolis once you
decide he's not credible as to Peyton
Manning why is he credible as to James
Harrison clay matthews Julius Peppers
and Mike Neal you can't be this is a
batting average you're either credible
or not so you're credible is the Peyton
Manning why doesn't that close the books
on these other interviews and I
personally think in this isn't this
isn't a report I believe after talking
to somebody who's in the know but not
directly involved in this that the
league made it known to these players
presumably through their agents just
show up answer the questions and you'll
be fine we have to do this together
these Patriots fans out here going crazy
about this stuff because of the whole
deflategate thing we have to at least
look like we're investigating just come
in and talk and will exonerate you the
same way that we exonerated paid Manning
the same way to baseball exonerated Ryan
Howard and Ryan Zimmerman yeah I feel
like there there was no way they were
going after Peyton Manning I mean there
was no benefit for the NFL to go to the
mat for Peyton Manning and see if he
used HTH these other guys I get the
feeling the same thing that hey and we
didn't go in on Payton to look it makes
us look like we're doing our job and
we're investigating you even though al
Jazeera's not even in business any
longer i I just I was just I assume that
they said if we get you guys in we're
going to have you come in this is why
we're going to have you come in then
come in and then we'll let you go and go
play games they do here's the problem
and this is why there was a dust-up and
a back and forth and it took weeks to
get to the point where these guys are
going to be interviewed it's hard for
the players and the players association
to trust the NFL in a situation like
this because we've seen multiple
occasions where the league office
reaches a conclusion before the
investigation here's what we conclude
and the investigation is about working
backward to find the evidence that they
can use to cram into the box that
they've already checked as guilty that's
exactly what happened I believe in
deflategate they came to the conclusion
the Patriots for cheating and all the
money that was spent on Ted wells wasn't
about doing a true
objective unbiased investigation it was
about finding evidence that would
support the conclusion that they made
the moment that they were measuring the
PSI and the footballs at halftime of the
AFC championship game so when you have
that fear you know because I'll go and
tell the truth what do you have to hide
I got nothing to hide but how do I know
that i'm going to take what i say and
twist it and warp it and the next thing
you know I'm guilty of something I
didn't do so I think that's why there
was a fight I think that's why it got to
the point where the players had asked
themselves we want to risk being
suspended for not cooperating and now i
think the hope is that they will just
say okay yeah nothing to see here
there's nothing to this report these
guys are exonerated and everybody can
move on yeah I don't blame these guys I
wouldn't trust the NFL what happens if
they say hey we want you to turn over
your phones because once we want to see
if there's any correspondence here oh
that's the concern that's one of the
concerns that the Union had okay fine
we'll go in and meet and will deny
everything and then the next request is
we want your phones and they got a lot
of stuff from Peyton Manning but it's my
understanding they didn't ask for and
therefore didn't receive his phone but
that that's a big part of this what's
the next request are you just going to
meet with this and exonerate us or are
we going to have to produce phones are
we going to have to do this so we're
going to have to do that when does this
all in and what evidence do you have if
any beyond the guy who number one
recanted his testimony although I don't
put a whole lot of stock into that I
think he was pressured into recanting
but number two we've already decided
that he's not telling the truth as the
Peyton Manning why are you relying upon
this guy's to the other four players
okay but why would the guy from the
Guyer Institute recant what he said well
well who pressured what you're saying
inflammatory things that are secret and
confidential and you're giving away
stuff about clients and if you aspire to
have a career in that business you're
not going to have much of a career if
you're out there talking to people about
all the people that are using peds so I
think that was one of the big reasons
why and there was a very lengthy report
in The Washington Post about the steps
that were taken by the Peyton Manning PR
machine and legal machine and I I think
that that based on that report from the
Washington Post I could see why the kid
would say how not messing with this i'm
just going to i recant everything well
what what do you reckon
we had everything whatever I said I
didn't say you know who I blame Oh Papa
John oh why I'll bet he probably put
some pressure on this guy ah they said
Papa J just said they sent him with a
bunch of gift cards for Papa John's ever
you thank ya baby mom the Tim Tebow
whirlwind tour for baseball we know he
has a strong arm is this a real story
here well it's a story because ESPN
wants it to be a story and whoever else
is pulling the strings and whatever the
endgame is I don't know what the endgame
is maybe it's just Tim Tebow selling a
bunch of baseballs in bath city signing
for 125 and a hundred seventy five
dollars a pop respectively but I feel
like this has all been engineered and
orchestrated and it just doesn't feel
real to me and it's funny every story I
see about this dan there's the
perfunctory paragraph about Tim Tebow
hitting 424 is a senior in high school
who cares I mean anybody who's any good
hits 500 at a minimum in in high school
baseball he hit 424 and he hasn't played
since 2005 and and I you know people say
oh how dare you chastise someone who's
pursuing his dreams look it's one thing
to pursue your dream brick by brick
piece by piece climbing the mountain I
feel like he wants to be airlifted to
the top of the mountain and I that's I
think at a certain level disrespectful
to all the guys who are out there triple
a double a single a riding on beaten
down buses and staying in fleabag motels
and eating crappy food and doing all the
stuff and all of them have more talent
than he does so I don't know what this
is I've been calling it a one-man
fantasy camp I think that's what it's
going to be next Tuesday I don't think
anybody's going to sign him unless
somebody's looking to sell some tickets
and some jerseys in the month of sep
tember is the mothership going to carry
this live mic well you know that's a
good question it's closed to the public
because god forbid anybody would want
free autographs when you're selling them
for 125 and 175 a pop on baseballs and
bats but all I have a feeling there'll
be a camera there and I have a feeling
that if you tune in to the mothership
next Tuesday you'll see something you'll
see something we see a lot of him
swinging a bat we never see where the
ball goes we see a lot of been swinging
a bat thank you might be that solid
I pursue his dream man he's just that
he's just a humble kid from Jacksonville
trying to trying to follow his dream of
course he is and that'll be the Disney
movie that we get maybe that will there
be a tebow disney movie mike within the
next what this is all about then maybe
they may be that this script is like
five pages like we need something more
here what can we do here hey how about
he goes and plays baseball okay let's do
that maybe that's good hey who owns ESPN
disney but we can't make this a 34-30
it's much larger than that those other
shows too much more money to be made oh
because listen and and this is why I get
myself into trouble every time I I
criticize or even remotely indirectly
scrutinized him Tebow there are millions
of people out there that love the guy of
course they think he got robbed by the
NFL I think he'd still be a
playoff-caliber quarterback in the NFL
if the teams would give him a chance
it's it's crazy how rabbits some people
are about not some people a lot of
people are about it but you could have
him performing circumcisions in a member
when he did that like yeah on a
religious mission with his dad and I
mean there's this is a movie hey it
maybe it's a trilogy oh maybe maybe this
is the equivalent of Return of the King
right Tim Tebow's baseball career maybe
you do college as the opening movie pro
as the the middle spot and then his
baseball career is the third act and you
make what a couple billion dollars and
everybody's happy thank you Mike except
me the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings
on audience